okay we now have the Donald Trump
Republican tax plan in its final form
for analysis and it is called the tax
cuts and Jobs Act of 2017 Trump wanted
to call it the cut cut cut Act 2017
something like that if I were to try and
I'm going to to sum up the plan in one
phrase it would be extremist ideological
deficit exploding swamp filling disaster
wrapped in populist good for the average
family dude language right that is the
one sentence and it's a very long
sentence but it is the one sentence
description I would assign we're gonna
get into the details of the plan but one
of the starkest and most depraved
signals about this plan is that Donald
Trump tells us it's it's uh not good for
him
but it actually is really really good
for him in fact it's mostly good for the
very rich and that that includes people
making four hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per year being considered low
and middle-income by the plan and people
who will be helped by the plan the
one-page document that Republicans
released brags about how it will lower
individual tax rates for low and middle
income Americans to zero twelve twenty
five and thirty five percent you can
earn under this plan four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year and be in
the thirty five percent tax rate that
apparently if you're a Republican counts
as being a low or middle income American
on what planet is four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars middle-class the facts
are that the median household income in
the u.s. is about fifty nine thousand
dollars now that's household not
individual right and there are no formal
definitions of the middle class in the
US but the Tax Policy Center says that
the middle quintile starts at forty
eight thousand dollars a year
okay so we have a sort of double
bamboozling that's taking place here
part one is the plan isn't good for the
actual middle class but part two is that
Trump and Republicans are bamboozling
you about the reality that even when
they are serious about helping the
middle class they aren't talking about
you they're talking about included under
that umbrella
middle-class people that earn up to four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year now let's discuss the specifics of
the plan the biggest place to start is
what are the tax brackets well the
number of tax brackets will be reduced
from seven to four if your household
makes for example $80,000 your rate will
decrease from 25 percent to 12 percent
under this plan that would save you
about ten thousand dollars a year now if
you earn nine hundred thousand dollars
your rate would decrease from thirty
nine point six percent to thirty five
percent a nice tidy savings of just over
forty thousand dollars so very quickly
when you look at these tax brackets you
realize that yes many people will see a
reduction in tax rates we'll see later
how deduction changes impact them but
for most people the dollar decrease in
taxes due it's going to be very very
small but the people who will save the
most are those who will earn who already
earn several hundred thousand dollars a
year or just over a million dollars per
year but as I said the tax brackets
alone don't tell us everything we need
to know what about deductions well the
standard deduction is going to be
doubled okay deductions decrease your
taxable income so if you opt to take the
standard deduction that's offered no
matter how much you actually spent in
deductible expenses you can choose to
take a standard deduction and we have an
image that outlines this as well you
reduce your taxable income who is more
likely to itemize deductions
well overwhelmingly people who make a
lot of money ninety two percent of
people earning over five hundred
thousand dollars a year itemize eighty
one percent of people earning between
one and five hundred thousand dollars a
year itemize so overall the people who
benefit most are the people who itemize
their deductions which are the very rich
on paper you say hey we're gonna double
the standard deduction and that's gonna
really help the little guy the average
person and it may but that is being
countered with some other changes
including the remove
full of a $4,000 per household member
exemption so this is deliberately
complex and the right is selling this as
this is going to make your taxes so
simple that you're gonna be able to fill
them out on a postcard and send it in
that's not true but for me more
interesting than what the size of the
piece of paper is that you can fill out
your taxes on I'm more concerned by is
this a fair tax plan and I don't mean
fair tax as the proper noun that some on
the right have created I just mean is it
fair and equitable and just is this
going to disproportionately help the
very rich the very poor the middle class
who is disproportionately going to be
helped and it is indeed the very very
rich pass-through income is also going
to be something that is going to change
it's a complicated algorithm I'm not
even going to get into it but it is
going to be better for people who earn
money through businesses that pass the
income through to the individual the
david pakman show as an example right
we're in S corporation the corporation
exists the corporation earns money but
the corporation other than a very small
Massachusetts excise tax doesn't pay
taxes the profit or loss passes through
to the owners of which I am one and I
pay taxes based on the money that is
earned by the corporation so this is
actually going to help me in that sense
no changes to the 401 K limit we did a
big expose on that last week there is
going to be a doubling of the exemption
on the estate tax and that is hugely
hugely regressive right now the estate
tax repeal is something that would only
impact couples who have a net worth of
over eleven million dollars right so it
only impacts those people there's
already an exemption on the estate tax
for a couple for their first 11 million
dollars in assets now this will be
doubled to 22 million dollars in assets
and this is going to impact 0.2 0.2
percent of the
population we hear about oh this is good
for the 1% this is good for the 0.2%
it'll help Trump Trump says it's not
going to be good for him maybe he's
right it'll be fantastic for him six
hundred million dollars would be saved
in passing Trump's money to his heirs
with this trump's cabinet would benefit
big lee from this if you take the
fifteen richest members of trumps
administration this estate tax change
would save them about 1.7 billion
dollars forget about the 1% this is for
the point two percent and this is also
bad for the environment the tax plan
they figured out a way to make the tax
plan hurt our planet right now there's a
federal $7,500 tax credit if you blot by
a plug-in electric car gone-gone under
this plan and in addition to that and i
can't believe that we even are having
this conversation
there's extremist religious language in
this tax bill if you look at page 93 of
the plan it says that you can designate
unborn children as beneficiaries in 529
college savings plans what is that a 529
college savings plan is a plan that a
parent or someone else can set up for a
child and you can set it up up until now
as soon as they are born this bill says
even unborn children can be the
beneficiaries of a 529 plan why is that
relevant
it is a backdoor way of making a law
that says life begins at conception if
you then say you don't even need a
social security number to have a 529
plan that you are the beneficiary of you
can be an unborn child
that could be a backdoor way to crowbar
in that life begins at conception
because after conception you can have a
529 plan you couldn't have a 529 plan if
you're not a person right so this plan
is an unmitigated disaster you might be
wondering well you're talking David
about all the people that will get a tax
cut how do you make up that lost revenue
and that is the exact question you
should be asking
if so many people are getting cuts
mostly of course the very rich the
government either needs to cut spending
which isn't happening or increase
revenues and the reality is that this
tax plan is not going to increase
revenues because if as I've told you
before and I will tell you again when
you cut the taxes on the very rich they
mostly save the money it is not
economically stimulative we've not seen
the scoring yet but that is what happens
we have until the end of the year really
to sort this out the House and Senate
will debate this in committees and
eventually try to virt merge their two
versions of the plan and they want to
pass this by the end of the year we will
be talking later in the week about what
we can do to try to prevent that from
happening the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad